Christina behin is a soprano at the
unhonest IATA in Dessau
she's performed all over Germany and
even in Japan
although she was born in Berlin Dessau
is her adopted hometown
ha hello it's been Christine hello my
name is Christina Baran and I've lived
in daesil for over 20 years because this
is where my dream job took me I am a
singer at the end halt dishes tiata I
live here with my daughter Hannah and
our dog Oscar and I'm thrilled that I'm
able to sing for a living today I'm
going to show you three of my favorite
places in the city and I hope you'll
like them too wouldn't have fun
first of all Kristina Bagon takes us to
a former butchers smoking tower a
perfect spot to get a bird's-eye view of
Dessau the industrial landmark is 25
meters tall and its viewing platform
opened in 2008
the theater is in the city centre which
isn't far away when its current building
opened in 1938 it boasted one of the
largest stages in Europe Ponyo there's a
wonderful view from up here of Dessau
and behind me you can see the theater
it's been staging plays for more than
200 years one professional is here at
Irish beer
DeSales main industrial landmark is this
nineteenth-century former brewery
the city was founded over 1,000 years
ago today it has a population of 80,000
and a reputation for being one of the
greenest towns in Germany Dalton's now
we're gonna head over there to the corn
house some con house
the corn house was built in 1930 it was
designed by architect Karl figa a close
colleague of Volta Gropius who founded
the Bauhaus School in Vemma in 1925 the
school moved to Dessau iffen it Sonia
Khanna I've just arrived at the corn
house one of the best known Bauhaus
buildings in town I'm a big fan of this
architectural style and now I'm going to
show you what it looks like inside he's
in a seat
the building overlooking the river
replaced an eighteenth-century granary
today the corn house is a listed
building it's seen as a masterpiece of
Bauhaus architecture
in 2012 it underwent extensive
restoration
the scone on the corn house is my
favorite restaurant in death south I
love the feel of the space and the view
of the Elbe it's priceless really
beautiful regional specialities are on
the menu
Christina Barnes third travel tip for
Dessau takes us to the desolates garden
realm a unesco world heritage site part
of it the louisiana garden was named in
honor of louisa duchess of unheard esau
some 250 years ago architectural
features such as the neo-gothic snake
house complete the picture we have Isis
guests they used to be the guest house
but today it can be rented one day I
would really really love to stay in it
the neoclassical Louisiana palace was
Louise's country house it was built in
the late 18th century a gift from her
husband Duke Leopold the third
Indy's makan this apparently used to be
Louise's dressing room I think it's the
loveliest room in the whole palace
the desolates garden realm became a
UNESCO World Heritage Site in the year
2000
you